Chris Paul was dishing and swishing to
use the collide Fraser phrases that I
used to hear as a kid growing up I
tweeted out cp3 is bawling out and our
next guest here on the Rich Eisen show
from the CSN Bay Area ray Ratto
responded with this fantastic suite a
disturbing visual no matter who you want
to win are you right well I'm gonna try
to choke down the vomit this is just re
induced into my morning it's so good
well good then let's turn the page if
you will how how is warrior nation
handling what occurred last night best
you can tell first blush day after right
first blush I think they're they're
heading for the roof sort of thinking
about anything at all because when
you're up 12 nothing you know that the
team to come back when you're up 12 in
the fourth quarter a lot home and you've
got a team basically ready to roll over
and then to find out not only are they
not going to roll over but they're gonna
get back in the game in two minutes and
make your life a living well I think
this is the first time that warrior fans
have come to grips with the fact that a
Houston is really really good too
Houston can do things to the Warriors
that other teams can't do and three this
series is actually in doubt and I don't
think that occurred to them before last
night so what best you can tell can the
Rockets do to the Warriors and other
teams can't that is repeatable two more
times over the next three games right
well just the way they defend they
they're they're better at crowding the
Warriors they're better at sort of what
hockey hockey people used to call clutch
and grab defense because in the
postseason the rules on all that stuff
were liberalized and you had a veteran
officiating crew last night that is used
to calling games that way and the
Warriors I think fall into this habit
way to offering for their own good of
getting on a run and thinking the other
team is just going to you know fall down
in a puddle of its own
spit and the Rockets don't do that they
are mean-spirited and ornery and tough
and stubborn and so when we're when the
lawyers go up they have they have the
runs they'll go up ten they'll go up
twelve the Rockets are capable of saying
no that's enough and very few teams are
capable of that now it didn't happen in
Game three they got blown out of the
building but in Game four they they got
their backs up and that's a matter of
will rather than skill and so I think
what happened with warrior fans to go
back to your earlier question is that
they found out that the Rockets are not
soft the Rockets are not weak and the
Rockets are are going to be the tough
out that people sort of said
intellectually they wanted they wanted
to see the Warriors tested now the
Warriors have been tested and they've
been found to be vulnerable and I think
that's a little unsettling for warrior
four is it safe great for us is it well
yeah I know a great for us for the
conversation ray I mean is it say is it
fair to say that that Steve Kerr is
getting tested as well that the
second-guess of him not calling a
timeout letting the Warriors continue
continue looking for that crucial shot
at the end of the game even though it
did appear that they weren't finding it
and clay Thompson got one off at a very
awkward position is is it is Steve Kerr
being second-guessed in that town this
morning um some although I think his
explanation satisfies most he doesn't
typically call timeout in those
situations because he has faith in his
players now where it starts to break
down though is when when the when the
often starts to break down at about six
seconds and draymond Green wants to call
a timeout and is trying to signal for
one but the officials aren't looking at
draymond Green they're looking at the
play and it's up to either draymond
Green to run up to one of the officials
and scream timeout in his face
or for Steve Kerr to sprint down the
sideline until he gets to an official
and screams time I mean it should he you
cannot let that part go to chance the
fact that they didn't call timeout right
away doesn't bother me but the fact that
once they decided they needed the
timeout that nobody went to
extraordinary lengths to get it is the
thing that they should be unhappy about
ray Ratto NBC Sports Bay Area here on
the Rich Eisen show how much faith can
you put in the into the argument well
andre igudala wasn't out there and the
team would be less tired as a whole as
they appeared in the fourth quarter and
obviously he also provides a spark and
an offensive and a defensive addition to
this team and that wouldn't have
happened had he been in Game four well
it might have happened had he been in
Game four because as much as he helps
them in terms of you know taking up
minutes that you wouldn't be giving to
say Quinn cook or Jordan Bell
necessarily um the other assumption is
that he would have been able to calm the
Warriors down and relocate their
equilibrium in the fourth quarter and
that one bothers me because the Warriors
are a veteran team they've been through
this 90 times if they can't figure out
how to calm themselves down and get
their offense back into sync on their
own then there's something wrong with
them and the other part about how
worried the Warriors got the Rockets
played basically a six-man rotation last
night for their starters played more
than 40 minutes and Eric Gordon played
34 so the Rockets were every bit as
tired I think the one difference is and
I don't know that it would Allah could
have made a difference here is that
physically the Rockets were taking their
toll on the Warriors they I guess that
they clutch they grabbed a body pump
they do things that good experience
playoff teams do and the Warriors didn't
cope with it well down the stretch and I
don't know that it would
would have been able to change that with
his mere presence now maybe the winners
are never in a position where you know
the Rockets can come back maybe that
12-point lead you know at some point
gets to 18 or 20 but that's unknowable
all I know is in crunch time the
Warriors had more than enough veteran
leadership to take care of their
business and they did it couple woman is
left with Ray Ratto NBC Sports Bay Area
insider do you think iguodala's back for
Game five what do you think I would
guess yes because one they need him and
two when he was upgraded from doubtful
to questionable typically that's the
warrior sending mystical that he's going
to play so that when he didn't play I
thought well he must be close enough
that he'll be available for Game five uh
it it probably you know helps them in a
way that he didn't play in Game four and
I suspect they probably thought they
could win without him in Game four but
now you know the margin for error is
down to zero you know they're they're
going to Houston which is not an easy
place to play the NBA playoffs this year
have been more home concentric than ever
before so that's going to be worth a
couple of points to the Rockets and the
Rockets have already established that
they're not afraid of the warrior
mystique a lot of teams still are but
the Rockets showed in the regular season
that they're not taking any more guff so
they're they're ready to go which means
that the Warriors you know if it would
Allah can go you have to assume that he
can go 25 27 minutes like usually does
so they don't really have a choice
if he can't go the way they normally use
him then maybe he's too hurt to play but
I'm gonna guess he plays I mean I guess
he's gonna play in this regular rotation
and is regular minutes right love the
chat appreciate the call and I always
enjoy the back-and-forth on Twitter
Raymond thank you very much okay I'm
gonna go take a knee now except
currently I can do that because I'm not
an employee in your company
well it's interesting there are new rule
did you see them have you seen them I
see them okay first blush thoughts
before I introduce them to my listening
and viewing audience shortly well on the
one hand the NFL is trying to solve a
problem that it really doesn't have but
they decided they do and two I've always
thought that patriotism is something
that grows in your hearts not on your
knee or not standing straight I think
it's one of those things that the NFL
tries to get involved with that it's not
very good at getting involved with
because you know they're picking
needless fights and the reminding people
of the things they don't do well instead
of just putting on football which is the
one thing that they should be really
good at all the time and when they let
things from the outside
become their focus they usually don't do
them well well I mean Jerry Jones Jerry
Jones wanted to say that he wants the
you know that that he wants people to
think of the NFL about who should be the
starting quarterback what happens in the
third quarter
not about the national anthem you don't
think the NFL had a problem with
viewership or attendance based on some
of the players kneeling during the
national anthem we're having a
demonstration during the national anthem
I think the NFL's attendance problem and
attention problem is more significant
than that and it's going to happen at a
much slower rate but it's got I just got
very little to do with whether guys
we're taking a knee or not I think it's
about the fact that football is kind of
diminishing at the grassroots level and
I think in some ways younger kids sort
of look at three and three half hours of
watching football as something dad does
I think the red zone you know allows
kids to at least watch it in shorter
bursts but I think this is a short short
attention span generation we helped
create and I think that football has got
to figure out how to regain that it's a
little bit of a problem baseball has and
in fact it's one of the things that the
former Commissioner the Canadian
Football League said that they've had
for
long time is that football is considered
the old guys sports they're gravitating
to other things or they're gravitating
away from sports I think that's a more
fundamental argument than you know they
might have lost a viewing point here or
there because somebody knelt and that's
not even proven empirically anyway I
think the NFL's
issues and again we're still talking
about a multi-billion dollar industry
are sort of there long term and they're
gonna you know continue to grow
incremental II until they can address
the notion that kids are not in the
football the way they used to be Raymond
that's a real issue Raymond always like
I said always appreciate the chat will
chat down the long yes yes we will
because you're a lovely lovely man right
back at you that's ray r @o @ r @ o NB
c-- s on twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience